sind jetzt alle wach hallo Arbeit
da braucht man weiß ich nicht Digger ich
möchte heute den teuersten Cocktail der
Welt machen oder den teuersten Cocktail
den ich jemals getrunken habe das hat
mich aber fragen lassen ob es
tatsächlich den teuersten Cocktail gibt
und natürlich gibt es dazu einen
Guinness World Record Eintrag klar ich
präsentiere euch Joel heffernance er ist
ein gefeierter Bartender
Melbourne crowns Club in Australien und
möchte den Rekord vom Vorgänger brechen
ein Jahr zuvor hat nämlich der
italienische badhändler Salvatore
Calabrese in London den Salvatore legen
Sie für
5500 Pfund serviert
5500 und der will das noch steigern
stellt euch mal vor ihr trinkt etwas was
so viel kostet wie ein Gebrauchtwagen
und das alles ist vor zehn Jahren
passiert das heißt das Geld ist jetzt
sogar noch mehr wert als damals am
17.02.2013 serviert Joel Heffernan den
the Winston für
12.970 australische Dollar und natürlich
kann man jetzt denken mit so ein
bisschen Blattgold und Kaviar kann man
den Preis schon hoch treiben aber nein
nein nein nein nein ich konnte die
Zutaten für diesen Cocktail herausfinden
und es ist eine Mischung aus age
Chartreuse VIP eine Quintessenz von
Grand Marnier und der 1858er
QW Leonie Cognac klar ihr kleinen
Sommeliers wisst natürlich welche Zutat
davon so teuer ist natürlich der Konjak
bei einer Versteigerung ging eine
Flasche für 185
über die
aktionsheke für diesen Preis könnte man
sich eine Einzimmerwohnung in Berlin
kaufen normal so als Vergleich aber der
kann Jack hat natürlich eine Geschichte
der den Preis
rechtfertigt er ist aber nicht nur Stein
als sondern wurde von den Trauben
hergestellt die von Julius Caesars Armee
55 vor Christus dort eingepflanzt wurden
diese Weinberge erlebten nach der Ernte
für diesen 1858 Leonie Konja Dings eine
Plage und zwar als die Reblaus nach
Europa kam BAM Europa hat es gerade
geschafft richtig viel und guten Wein
herzustellen und dann hat sie alles
kaputt gemacht
[Musik]
irgendwann haben sie das Problem dann
aber auch gelöst ich kann euch jetzt nur
nicht zu viel davon erzählen weil sonst
schweife ich komplett ab es geht ja um
den Cognac der wurde zur Hochzeit von
Leonie kreuzt erstmalig abgefüllt wie
spricht man es aus Cousin Cousin
kleiner fun fact 1805 hat Leon Cousine
diesen Laden gegründet und es ist das
älteste Haus der Welt das Konjak
herstellt und falls jetzt wie ich total
auf den Geschmack gekommen seid und
diesen Cognac probieren wollt ihr könnt
das sogar im interkontinental in
Hongkong tun es ist das einzige Hotel
auf der Welt in dem man diesen Konja
probieren kann und ein shot mit 40 ml
bekommt ihr auch schon für
1700 und 64 Dollar bin aber auch nicht
Kelly und gebe tausende von Euros für
meine Videos aus deswegen versuchen wir
den heute so ein bisschen nachzumachen
und mal zu gucken wie er so schmeckt ich
habe rausgefunden dass dort zwei Shots
von dem Konjak drin sein sollen die sind
schon glaube ich 6000 $ wert die
Quintessenz von Grand Marnier der kostet
ungefähr 800 $ und ein super seltener
Chartreuse VIP das ist so ein Kräuter
Likör zum Glück gibt es diese Zutaten
aber auch für real existierende Menschen
wie mich und ich habe mich für die
Zutaten entschieden unser Cognac stammt
heute aus dem Hause Remi matter da steht
eine 1738 drauf das bedeutet dass dieser
konjugiert bestimmt richtig super
schmeckt man bekommt ihn für sage und
schreibe
54,90 € auf Amazon den Link findet ihr
in der Beschreibung frech daher kommt
der Grand man ja da steht eine 1827
drauf was wir auch ganz klasse finden
dieser Orangenlikör kostet uns sage und
schreibe 40 € und zu guter Letzt unser
Chartreuse Kräuterlikör da steht 1605
drauf und das finden wir noch viel
besser
was kann ich dir bringen Winston ja klar
manche gerne 12.000 $ bitte
ich habe mich natürlich nicht lumpen
lassen und wunderschöne Gläser gekauft
die perfekt für den Winston passen
die waren auch wirklich nicht günstig
24 € für zwei solche Gläser wow
sind ja ganz schick aber die sind sehr
klein jetzt machen wir den Cocktail im
Glas mit so einem schönen großen Löffel
und die Zubereitung ja hier ist unser
wunderbarer Cognac seid ihr eigentlich
Cognac Trinker ich habe das erste und
einzige Mal Cognac benutzt für meine
Ochsenbäckchen als ich beim perfekten
Promi Dinner mitgemacht habe ja sonst
habe ich nicht viel mit Konjak zu tun es
ist jetzt wirklich auch nicht so ein
Alkohol den man sich im Club bestellt
und denkt jawollo ich mache das schon
mal Eis rein
bin richtig aufgeregt nicht nur weil es
mit einem Tag ist und ich jetzt ähm ein
bisschen Alkohol trinken werde aber ich
finde das ist was sehr bewegendes aber
warum sind traurig weil sonst kommt
jetzt eigentlich nur mit Kelly und frei
machen so zwei Shots ein shot ist ja
eigentlich zwei zählen ne
riecht man
kann ja so
hmm das ist was ganz feines schmecke
die Trauben noch sehr stark durch YUM
YUM YUM ein shot noch ein shot to Schatz
von der nächsten Zutat brauchen wir eine
Quintessenz eine Quintessenz das Wesen
einer Sache das endgültige Ergebnis
dessen was man aus allem vorher
gegangenen schlussfolgen kann
oh das riecht ganz fein
oder
[Musik]
ja und jetzt kommt noch der letzte
Kandidaten
orange Kräuter Cognac das klingt für
mich nach einem guten Abend bitte schön
ist diese Flasche ihn genehm ja
jetzt rühren wir den Cocktail
[Applaus]
dieses Video sogar so ein Ding geholt
nice wow so und das können wir das in
unser Glas bitte drauf
das ist ja meine Freunde der sieht sehr
beschreiben er sieht sehr dickflüssig
aus wenn ich das mal so sagen darf aber
er sieht genauso aus wie auf den Bildern
der teuerste der Welt
zu probieren zur Mitte zum Sack zack
zack zack
es ist offiziell ich bin Alkoholiker mir
schmeckt es ich weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen soll probiere noch mal ein
bisschen
also ich habe erwartet dass er viel
stärker schmeckt und viel mehr im Hals
brennt und einem so dieses Gefühl von so
einem Wodka shot gibt wo man alles
einfach nur so zusammenziehen aber der
ist eigentlich ganz weich willst du den
probieren
man fühlt sich auf jeden Fall sehr
erwachsen wenn man so sitzt und sich
denkt hey ich trinke nur Alkohol nee nee
das ist nichts das nichts anderes drin
auch schon ganz schön warm ich weiß
natürlich nicht wie Arsch auf ein geile
originale geschmeckt hat ne mit dem
Cognac der wahrscheinlich der leckerste
Cognac der Welt ist ich finde aber schon
das ist so ein Cocktail Rezept das kann
man sich schon mal in der Bar bestellen
man muss aber sehr langsam trinken ich
bin immer von Moskau Julian sowas
gewöhnen dass man das halt so ein
bisschen ne sich reinzimmern kann
aber das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Ding
langsam
ich hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen
wenn ja dann zeigt man mit einem Daumen
nach oben unten findet ihr alle Produkte
die ich für dieses Video benutzt habe da
ist auch mein Amazon Store Front ich
habe jetzt nämlich gerade gelernt dass
ich einen storefront habe da könnt ihr
reinschauen und ich packe da so Produkte
in Listen und dann ist da z.B was drin
wie mein Video Equipment oder zu
speziellen Videos die ich hochlade dann
sind da halt einzelne Kategorien und da
könnt ihr euch dann durch Klicken viel
Spaß in eurem Leben wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder eure Barkeeperin
Vanessa
Gott ich nehme den ich nehme die Daumen
Pistole zurück ich nehme sie zurück und
das freut mich nicht mehr an